The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
INSTRUCTOR: So let's
consider a reaction
and consider the
effect of temperature
on this reaction on the
thermodynamics of the reaction.
So this is the decomposition
of sodium bicarbonate.
Does anyone know what another
name for bicarbonate is?
If you were going to send
someone to the grocery store
to buy some, what would
you tell them to get?
AUDIENCE: Baking soda.
INSTRUCTOR: So
you would probably
say, look for baking soda.
Does anyone know what this
is used for or how it works?
AUDIENCE: Baking.
INSTRUCTOR: Baking, yes.
So what is baking soda doing?
What step of baking
are you using it for?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: Yeah, bread rising.
So in this reaction,
you're forming gas,
and that gas helps
bread to rise.
So this process happening
while it's baking
allows for bread rising
and things like that.
So baking soda-- you always
want to make sure you
add your baking soda.
So let's consider
the thermodynamics
of this reaction.
delta H0 is a positive
value, 135.6 kilojoules.
And why don't you tell
me which of these you
think is going to be the
delta S of these options?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
INSTRUCTOR: Just
10 more seconds.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
INSTRUCTOR: So the
positive value--
that is a very good guess
and that is correct.
Because we're going
from solids to gases,
so you would predict that
entropy would be increasing.
Things are not moving
very much with a solid.
With a gas, they can.
You have more
disorder, more freedom.
So that is, in fact,
the correct value
for this delta S0 is
plus 0.334 kilojoules.
I already put it in
kilojoules for you.
And now we can calculate the
delta G for this reaction.
And let's first do it
at room temperature.
So we have delta H, positive
value and endothermic reaction.
We're doing it at
room temperature
first, in Kelvin so we
can cancel our units.
And we put in our
delta S value here.
And then we can
calculate it out.
And delta G0 is plus
36.1 kilojoules per mole
That is not a
spontaneous reaction.
So our bread is
not going to rise,
and our baking will be failed,
except that we're probably
not going to be baking it in
the oven at room temperature.
So this would be non-spontaneous
but when we bake,
we're going to heat the
oven, and so usually 350
or something, which
is 450 Kelvin.
So now we can do
the equation again.
We plug-in our delta H, our new
temperature, and our delta S,
and we get a negative value.
Delta G0 is minus
14.7 kilojoules
per mole at 450 degrees Kelvin.
So this would be spontaneous.
So when you're baking,
you want to remember
to turn your oven on,
heat it up, and put
in your baking soda.
So let's think about now
this type of reaction
that has a positive delta
H and a positive delta S.
So these both have
the same sign.
And if both delta H and
delta S have the same sign,
temperature can be used
to control spontaneity.
It will be non-spontaneous
at one temperature
but spontaneous at
another temperature.
And if we assume
delta H0 and delta
S0 are independent
of temperature, which
is fine to do-- that's
a good assumption-- then
delta G0, which is definitely
dependent on temperature,
is linear-- is a linear
function with temperature.
So let's plot now those
two values of delta
G that we just calculated.
So here is our plot.
We have delta G0 kilojoules
per mole on the y-axis
and temperature on the x-axis.
And let's put in the
numbers that we had.
So we had calculated at
room temperature, around 300
Kelvin, a value of about
26-- positive 26 kilojoules
per mole.
And we calculated
then at about 450
Kelvin a value about
minus 14.7, almost
minus 15 kilojoules per mole.
And when you have
two points, you
can draw a beautiful
straight line.
When you have more, sometimes
it's more complicated.
But it is linear.
Delta G0 is linear
with temperature.
So now let's think about
this is a straight line,
and we can think about an
equation for a straight line.
So the equation that
we know and love,
delta G0 equals delta H minus T
delta S, can be now rearranged.
We have delta G on
the y-axis here.
We have temperature
is our x-axis.
So now we've just rearranged.
We've pulled minus
delta S0 over here,
and delta H0 are over here.
So delta H is our y-intercept.
And for some reason, your
notes just say "y dash i."
I don't know what happened
to "intercept" part.
But anyway, that's the
y-intercept is delta H0.
And what is the slope?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: Yeah.
So the slope is
negative delta S.
So if you plotted delta
G's versus temperature,
you could get out your delta
H, or you could get out
from the slope your delta S.
And let's think about these
different parts of the plot.
So over here delta
G is greater than 0.
It's of positive value.
And what does that mean
about the spontaneity
of the reaction, if its
delta G is positive?
AUDIENCE: Non-spontaneous.
INSTRUCTOR: Right, so
that's non-spontaneous.
Down here, we have delta G
minus value less than zero,
so there it's spontaneous.
So at some temperatures, the
reaction is non-spontaneous,
and in other temperatures,
the reaction is spontaneous.
And there is a certain
value of T, T star,
that is the temperature
at which it switches
from non-spontaneous
to spontaneous,
or if you're
decreasing temperature,
spontaneous to non-spontaneous.
And for a particular
reaction, you
can calculate what
that temperature
value is, what T star is.
So let's do that.
So we can calculate T star.
And so again, this is
the temperature at delta
G equals 0 where
you have that switch
point between spontaneous
and non-spontaneous.
So we can set delta
G0 equal to 0.
And then we can
solve for T star.
So T star would just be
delta H0 over delta S0,
because this is set to 0.
And we can plug these values in.
So delta H, again, was plus
136 kilojoules per mole.
And delta S0 was plus 0.334
kilojoules per Kelvin per mole.
And we can calculate out a
temperature of 406 Kelvin.
So this is the
temperature at which
you have this switch
from a spontaneous
to a non-spontaneous process.
So if you're cooking
your bread below 406,
you get something
that looks like this.
The first time-- my husband
is the chef in our family.
And the first time I was
tasked with making cupcakes
for my daughter's
school, I forgot
to put the baking soda in.
But if you put
enough frosting on it
and the kids are four years
old, it totally doesn't matter.
Anyway, if I had put
in the baking soda
and cooked it at temperatures
above 406 Kelvin,
I would have had something
that looked a whole lot better,
and I wouldn't have even
had to put frosting on.
But, no, I would have.
Four years old, you have to
put frosting-- never mind.
It all worked out.
So there is this
temperature at which
you have a switch if the sign of
delta H and the sign of delta S
are the same.
So now let's think
about another case
where you have
delta H0 and delta
S are both negative values.
What would this plot look like?
And here are some
options for you.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
INSTRUCTOR: Let's just
do 10 more seconds.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
INSTRUCTOR: 90%, excellent.
So that is correct.
So we can draw that
now in your handout.
So here, if they're
both negative,
down here we have delta S is
a negative value, spontaneous.
You'll have a negative
delta G. And here
you have a negative delta H
minus T times a negative delta
S. So this will
be a positive term
and this will be
a negative term.
And to be spontaneous, you
want a negative overall.
So at low temperatures,
the unfavorable delta S
is down-weighted.
So at low temperatures,
you're spontaneous.
But as the
temperature increases,
you'll get to a magic
temperature, a T star,
in which this delta S
term now becomes greater
than the delta H term.
This will be a big positive
value compared to a smaller
one, and you'll switch
to a positive delta G
and a non-spontaneous process.
Let's consider all
the options now.
One more.
10 more seconds.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
INSTRUCTOR: Great.
Yeah, I knew those
other clicker questions
were going to be deciding
the winners, I feel like.
So yes, this is always
going to be spontaneous.
So if we remember the equation--
and if you don't have it
memorized yet, you will soon.
Even though it will be
on an equation sheet,
most people don't need it.
You use it so much.
So when delta H0 is negative
and this is positive,
delta G is always
going to be negative.
So it'll always be
spontaneous, and so
when delta G0 will
always be negative
at every single temperature.
So now let's think
about this one.
Positive delta H, negative
delta S-- what will this be?
You can just yell it out.
AUDIENCE: Never.
AUDIENCE: Never
spontaneous, right.
So positive, and then here
with another positive, a minus,
a minus, another positive--
it'll never be spontaneous.
How sad for it.
So delta G will always be
positive at all temperatures.
So here are cases where
delta H and delta S
have different signs.
But now we have cases
where they're both positive
or they're both negative.
So for the both
positive case, this
will be sometimes spontaneous.
It will depend on T.
So when will delta G
be negative and, therefore,
the reaction be spontaneous,
when T is greater or
smaller than T star?
AUDIENCE: Greater.
INSTRUCTOR: Greater, right.
So here, we have a positive
delta H endothermic reaction.
We have a positive delta S.
And so when T is big here,
this term will dominate.
And you can still get
a negative delta G0, so
when temperatures are above
that magic temperature.
And then our last case, when
we have a negative delta
H, an exothermic reaction,
and a negative delta S0--
and again, that will
depend on temperature.
So when they have
the same signs,
temperature makes a difference.
And here, you will
have a negative delta G
when you have a smaller
temperature, because here you
want the delta H term.
That's a negative term.
And you want that to
be the bigger term,
and so you want to have
smaller temperatures that
will down-weight the
negative delta S0 over here.
So these are our four
possibilities-- always
spontaneous; never spontaneous;
and then sometimes spontaneous,
and it depends on the
temperature compared to T star.
And T star, again,
is the temperature
at which you switch
between spontaneous
and non-spontaneous.
So temperature is important.
Temperature is important
to thermodynamics,
and temperature is also
important to kinetics.
Most of the time, you can speed
up a reaction, or at least
an elementary reaction, when
you increase the temperature.
So now, let's think
about thermodynamics
in biological systems, and
think about a very important
interaction in
biological systems which
is hydrogen bonding.
So this is also great review
for the exam on Monday.
So hydrogen bonding
are interactions
between hydrogen bond donors.
So what is a
hydrogen bond donor?
A hydrogen bond donor is a
hydrogen in a polar bond.
So this is why it's good review
for exam 2 because for exam 2
you should be able to identify
polar and non-polar bonds.
So a hydrogen bond donor is
a hydrogen in a polar bond,
and a hydrogen bond acceptor
is an electronegative atom
with a lone pair.
And electronegativity is
also a topic on exam 2,
so might as well
learn it for Monday
and then continue to learn
it, because you'll also
need it for thermodynamics
and later on as well.
So here we have a bond between
something X and a hydrogen,
and here we have y that's
an electronegative atom
with a lone pair.
And this little,
squiggly plus thing
here indicates that it has
a partial positive charge.
And here you have
a negative charge,
and that's going to make for
a nice favorable interaction,
this hydrogen bond.
So X is something that
will lead to a polar bond,
such as nitrogen,
oxygen or fluorine,
nitrogen and oxygen
being the most
relevant to biological systems.
So if you have N or O
here, that's a polar bond.
And so that will then
form a hydrogen bond
with an electronegative
atom that has a lone pair.
And examples of that are also
nitrogen, oxygen, fluorine,
and nitrogen and oxygen,
again, being the most relevant
for biological systems.
So we have this interaction
because these sort
of partial charges here that
form this nice hydrogen bonding
interaction.
So if we look at one of the
most important molecules
that hydrogen bonds
which is water,
we see that water has polar
bonds between the oxygen
and the hydrogen,
because those have
electronegativity difference
of greater than 0.4,
and it has two lone pairs.
So water is capable of
being a hydrogen bond
donor with its hydrogen and
also a hydrogen bond acceptor.
And so if we draw the hydrogen
bonds as dotted lines here,
we see this OH polar bond
is a hydrogen bond donor,
and this oxygen here
with its lone pair
is the hydrogen bond acceptor.
So here we have this network of
hydrogen bonding interactions,
both on the board
and on my t-shirt.
I also have water-hydrogen
bonding on my t-shirt today.
So these hydrogen bonds in water
are really important for life.
This is a very, very
important property.
Now just for exam review, what
is the shape of that molecule?
AUDIENCE: Bent.
INSTRUCTOR: What angle do we
expect between the hydrogen,
oxygen, and the nitrogen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: Less than 109.5.
That's right.
What would be the SN number?
AUDIENCE: 4.
INSTRUCTOR: 4, Yes.
Good!
If those answers seem like "I
have no idea what everyone's
talking about," you
know what your weekend
is going to involve.
Those are things that are
going to be on the exam.
VSEPR, yes.
So let's compare now hydrogen
bonds with covalent bonds.
So here we have a hydrogen
bond donor and acceptor
versus a covalent interaction.
So a covalent interaction
where you have a bond,
where you have
bonding electrons are
being shared between the two.
So covalent bonds are stronger
than hydrogen bonds, for sure.
And let's look at some examples.
So if we consider
this X as an oxygen
here, in a oxygen hydrogen
polar bond interacting
with another oxygen, the
value for that hydrogen bond
would be about 20
kilojoules per mole
as opposed to the covalent
bond, here just the hydrogen
and oxygen, has 463
kilojoules per mole.
So the hydrogen bond
is considerably weaker
than a covalent bond,
but it's still--
weak bonds turn out
to be really important
in biological systems.
Now let's consider
a case where we
have nitrogen as the acceptor.
So we're going to have a
nitrogen acceptor here.
So if this is OH
donating to N, then we
have 29 kilojoules per mole.
NH interacting with N14,
compare to a covalent bond
between H and N of 388.
So when you compare
to covalent bonds,
hydrogen bonds are much
less, but they are still
super important.
So for bonds that are made
up between molecules here--
intermolecular, between
molecules-- hydrogen bonds
are the strongest kind
of interactions that
are between molecules here.
So hydrogen bonds can
be between molecules.
They can also be made
within a molecule.
So this just shows
hydrogen bonding
in a protein structure
between these
are called beta strands here.
And hydrogen bonding
is incredibly
important in forming protein
structure-- really, really
important.
So hydrogen bonds are
responsible for protein
folding-- very
important in proteins.
Hydrogen bonds are also
really important for DNA.
So all of the main in RNA, all
of our macromolecular molecules
of life, hydrogen bonding
is really important.
So let's look at a GC base
pair that forms in DNA.
And we can think about
the hydrogen bonds here.
So here are three of them.
So we have this polar
bond between N and H.
And it's the
hydrogen bond donor,
and we have the lone pair on
oxygen accepting that hydrogen
bond.
Here we have a polar bond
between nitrogen and hydrogen
donating over here to
a nitrogen lone pair.
And here we have an NH polar
bond as a hydrogen bond donor
to the lone pair on this oxygen.
And this hydrogen bonding
pattern is what
allows DNA to have
its beautiful double helix,
and is very, very important.
So why don't you give
it a try and tell me
how many hydrogen bonds you
would get between these guys
here.
And I'll leave this
structure up so you
can see what it looks like.
10 seconds.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
INSTRUCTOR: The answer is 2.
Let's take a look
at that over here.
So you have a
nitrogen polar bond
over here making an interaction
with this lone pair.
You have a polar NH pond
here, hydrogen donor
to this lone pair.
Why is that not a hydrogen bond?
Because it is carbon hydrogen.
So carbon hydrogen, the
electronegativity difference
is not greater than 0.4,
so carbon hydrogen is not
a polar bond.
So you need to have
both a polar bond,
and you need to have an
electronegative atom that
has lone pairs to be the
hydrogen bond acceptor.
So here you have a
hydrogen bond acceptor,
but you don't have a
hydrogen bond donor.
And so this actually
turns out to be important
because you want to
specifically recognize
one base with another base,
and so the hydrogen bonding
pattern is essential
for that working out.
So here, these are
hydrogen bonds.
I said they're weaker
than covalent bonds,
but they're strong
enough to help
stabilize the structure of DNA.
But they're not so strong
that DNA cannot unzip.
And you need to
unzip DNA to read it,
and by reading, that's
essential to make another copy,
to have cell division, or to
translate your genetic code.
So that's, I think,
why hydrogen bonds are
so important in biology,
because you don't want
a lot of super strong bonds.
You want weaker interactions
because in biology things
are moving around.
So let's talk about the
importance of hydrogen bonding.
And for this we have another
In Their Own Words segment.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name is Lourdes
Aleman, and my research
is on RNA interference or RNAi.
RNA interference is simply
a silencing mechanism
the cells use to turn down
the expression of a gene.
Double-stranded RNA pieces have
some sort of complementarity
to a sequence within the genome.
That double-stranded RNA piece
binds to a big large protein
complex, it unwinds the
double stranded piece,
takes one of those strands
only, and finds the gene
that it complements with.
And once it does, it binds
to that particular RNA
from that gene
and it destroys it
and not allowing protein
to be made from that RNA.
DNA and RNA both can form base
pairs by hydrogen bonding.
The short piece of RNA that
is found in this protein
complex guides that
RNA and basically finds
its match by hydrogen bonding.
So if it forms a hydrogen
bond along the whole entire
sequence, in knows it has
found a match somewhere
in the sequence.
And that's how it recognizes
the gene that its targeting.
Macular degeneration is
a disease of the retina.
There are too many blood
vessels in the retina,
and they can bleed
and scar over time,
and eventually these
patients can become blind.
Some patients with
this disease, one
of the reasons they have
an outgrowth in the retina
is because there is a gene
called the VEGF that there's
too much of.
And VEGF tells cells,
"Make blood vessels."
RNA interference is
being used to silence
the expression of this gene so
that in patients with macular
degeneration, you don't get
further growth of more blood
vessels and more bleeding and
scarring as a consequence.
My dream for RNAi would
be that as a patient
you will go into the doctor
if you were diagnosed
with some sort of disease.
The doctor would go
into the computer,
order you a some double-stranded
RNA for the particular gene
that has been mutated or is
malfunctioning in your disease,
and you would then
come back, and they
would put that
double-stranded RNA into you,
and you will get better.
That would be my
dream, that it could
be applicable to pretty much
any disease or viral infection
that you can think of.
How many of you have heard
of like RNAi or treatments
and things and sort of--
a number of people--
like customized medicine.
I mean, I think that that would
be such an incredible thing
if this works out, to really be
able to treat every individual
based on their DNA.
So we're not there
yet, but there's
a lot of people who
are working on this.
And there's a lot being
done at MIT research in RNA,
and that particular work was
in Phil Sharp laboratory.
Phil Sharp is one of our
Nobel laureates here at MIT.
So that's why hydrogen
bonding is important.
So let's just do one more
example of thermodynamics
in biological systems.
And we're back to
thinking about ATP,
which we talked about already,
and the hydrolysis of ATP.
So we saw that this is a
spontaneous reaction before,
and this can be what's
called "coupled"
to a spontaneous
process to drive
that non-spontaneous reaction.
So the total change in free
energy of a coupled reaction is
the sum of the
individual delta G's.
So if you have one that is
unfavorable and one that's
favorable, one that's positive
and one that's negative,
you sum that up and if
it's overall negative,
then it will become a
spontaneous coupled reaction.
So let's look at
this example again.
So we have delta G 0
for ATP at 310 Kelvin.
Why do you think I'm using 310?
What do you think
that temperature is?
AUDIENCE: Body temperature.
INSTRUCTOR: Body temperature.
So we have ATP, so you
have triphosphates--
that's the TP-- and hydrolysis.
You're losing one
of the phosphates.
You're going to a diphosphate.
And hydrolysis means a cleavage
reaction that involves water.
So we saw before that the
delta H0 for this is negative.
It's an exothermic reaction
minus 24 kilojoules per mole.
Delta S0 is plus 22 joules
per Kelvin per mole.
And so if we plug this
into our delta G equation,
we have delta H minus T
delta S. At body temperature,
this is a negative value,
negative 31 kilojoules
per mole.
So this is spontaneous.
The hydrolysis of
ATP is spontaneous.
Now we want to couple
this to something
that's non-spontaneous.
And the reaction
we're going to couple
to that's non-spontaneous is the
addition of a phosphate group
to glucose.
And this keeps the
glucose in the cell,
because things that have
charge can't come and leave
the cell as readily.
So nature often
does this, its way
of holding the
things that it wants
inside the cell inside the cell.
But this is a
non-spontaneous process.
The delta G0 is plus
17 kilojoules per mole,
but if we couple that to
the hydrolysis of ATP, which
is minus 31 kilojoules per mole,
and we can add those together,
so 17 minus 31, gives us
minus 14 kilojoules per mole.
And now this non-spontaneous
reaction is driven forward.
So we've taken something
that wasn't favorable
and made it favorable by
coupling it to ATP hydrolysis.
So if ATP hydrolysis is so
favorable and it's spontaneous,
why isn't it happening
all the time,
which would be really bad
for us because we store
our energy in the form
of ATP, so we want
to keep it in its good form?
And the answer
again is kinetics.
It's a slow process.
So ATP is inert enough
that we can use it
as an energy storage.